Quand on voit une image comme ça tout le monde a
vu une image comme ça déjà on on remarque qu'il
y a une sorte de bande blanche dans le ciel
qui s'appelle la Voie Lactée mais lorsqu'on
regarde le ciel la nuit on n'en voit jamais
qu'un petit bout de la Voie Lactée pour la
voir pour la voir en entier il faudrait qu'on
puisse prendre des photos de chaque nuit de la
Terre et de les rassembler ensuite en ayant
fait le tour du monde et ben c'est ce qu'a
fait un un télescope européen qui s'appelle
Gaia qui a pris quelques dizaines de milliers
photographies du ciel la nuit et qui les a mises
bout à bout et ça a donné ça l'image que vous
voyez là c'est une vraie photo enfin c'est un
amalgame de dizaines de milliers de photos qui
ont été mises bout à bout en gros c'est ce que
vous verriez là maintenant si la Terre était
transparente si les murs étaient transparents si on
était dehors et que vous pouviez voir l'Univers en
entier partout sans être pollué par les lumières
terrestres on verrait quelque chose comme ça